ci stiamo avvicinando alla fine non
siamo ancora arrivati ma ci stiamo
avvicinando nuovi episodi di the
wardrobe buona visione
[Musica]
ma cuocere una location nuova nel
frattempo ma chi è questo ma chi è
c'è molto vecchia conoscenza va bene ma
chi era quello non ho capito che ero il
tipo con i capi diversi vabbè arte post
moderna e ci hai ragione ma son rotto
descrive guardi infami c monumenti
capisci si ci penserò magari mi verrà in
mente qualcosa bella che regga
buongiorno è bellissimo sto parlando bar
bonamini non abbastanza per lasciarlo
riposare stavolta a proposito di mani
c'è quella di assassin's creed per terra
in questo videogame i modi di dire
vengono presi un po troppo alla lettera
perché ho trovato lago
ho trovato l'ago nel pagliaio covoni di
paglia va bene per andos che salvini lo
metta dislike al video ho notato che c'è
un marionettista senza testa di sopra
che sta comandando la zynga cosa tutta
questa perplessità non hai mai visto una
marionetta io ti posso dare il ticket
come l'iva un buon alla giostra o amen
qualcuno se l'è preso stocchi che il
maledetto scegli un premio piacere
qualsiasi cosa qualsiasi cosa set lego
del millennium falcon ultimate
collector's amico senza gambe della
principessa pd vorrei l'amico senza
gambe della principessa peach ho finito
l'ultimo disponibile astoi e guarda cade
lo sfortunato posso darti questo
[Musica]
brega è un regalo a caso premio fra
tutti al mare maledizione che ancora non
è sempre così è arrivato finalmente lo
scienziato il tipo macchina del tempo
quindi è arrivato il pezzo che c'è
funziona tutto adesso il corriere si è
fatto desiderare non poco mai il
carburatore era perfetto c'è solo un
piccolo problema ho finito il plutonio
celo celo celo come si mette però svetta
apri apri apri non saprei davvero da che
parte cominciare
che cosa me ne frega dalla lui plutonio
ha detto che doveva versare di cesare a
me fai tu fai tu zio ma a bomber o cosa
vuoi kacar e affetto perché se mi
chiedeva di mettere la dose non avevo la
più pallida idea fatto
se entriamo destinazione 1863 assicuri
bassi dai raid
c'è una giratempo nella macchina del
tempo va bene che figata
e quindi la cosa come la spiaggia era
uguale donne che c'è un nuovo di toghe b
salve signor monet manet buon dio chi
vola di grazia sì insomma sono l'oscuro
mietitore non era mia intenzione
spaventarla signor man e la sua fama la
precede sa lei mi lusinga
ora basta con i convenevoli non sono qui
per questo immagino che sia giunta la
mia ora corretto ma non del tutto esatto
potrei darle una seconda possibilità
qualsiasi cosa non mi risparmi la vita
la prego mi aggiunga nel suo quadro
allora il mare possibilmente in grande è
ben visibile quindi sono sono entrato
nel quadro rimane da parlare con i miei
segnalati
no non sbaglia a nokia niente sono morto
nei pesci ci pensavo di dover cliccare
mi sta bene
la prossima volta sarà il caso che mi
faccio gli affari miei ma adesso i pesci
sapranno di morto porca vacca c'è
nient'altro che posso fare qua no
e stato divertente ragazzi ho fatto
perché poi ci sta la cravatta
giustamente adesso lo scemo io sei qua
ci va proprio non sbagliato scusate
forni
[Musica]
si è aperta con una strada non c'era
neanche il cadavere la strada venne
fiaccola prendi prendi un altra e più
accesa e poi raccolta fai fai almeno
l'arrogante che ti ammazza fiammiferi
posso mio dio questo sto vedendo reagan
ok test in salamoia ve carino come
pretendi che possa parlare a delle teste
in salamoia mantenuto creato non valga
lo stesso per te va beh abbiamo step di
savoia
poi ci sono io quando mette gli occhiali
e mi farci crescere tanti capelli
daniele doesn't matter e clapis con gli
occhiali ma non sapevo come chiamarlo
avvenne non sapevo come chiamarlo di
governo e non sapevo come chiamarlo dico
bene non so più come più mauri corso è
il tuo nome
io non ho un nome forse proprio perché i
tuoi genitori non sapevano come
chiamarti quindi ho ragione io è il tuo
nome che ti è successo al braccio ma
cosa deve aver fatto un male cane magari
raggiungermi più tardi ok tu che faccia
lo sta dicendo so fare qualcos'altro in
un mostro marino suggerire un bravo
estetista se mi è permesso
macché che è un bagno immagini e
simpatico zombie buonasera
ciao bello si chino non sembra
troppissimo enzo miccio solo un po più
blu oddio ma cos'è questa puzza che deve
assolutamente fare un bel bagno
prendi va bene grazie signor zombie però
non mi ha detto come mi vesto quindi va
bene per garantirlo sfottere la targa
posso [ __ ] la targa è cosa mi serve a
niente ma tengo jones terni è arrivato
il momento di evocare satana amici miei
pentacolo bambola vo di supermario lo
chiamo lele peggio satana the ok
pensieri negativi
non voglio proprio sapere a cosa ha
pensato
niente di più semplice tutto merito
della facilità con cui riverso il mio
odio gratuito sulle persone capisco se
uno spillo giallombardo ovviamente
adesso sì anche prince
speriamo solo che questa sia la volta
buona e prima è prima non ho provato a
farlo ho capito c'era johnny bravo
dentro ok si va bene qui era bambola
voodoo di giorni per tutto sto bordello
per fa chiamare macchiava equo per me
tutto sto casino per far chiamare dico
del vecchio per poi farmi portare la
ramaio c'è ma io non ho parole ha fatto
un disastro
comunque johnny bravo è uscito fuori la
camera da letto al piano di sopra e
libera come promesso davvero svegliata
di gabbo subito la banda grandi con i
ragazzi e andate alla discarica non
interessa pd cosa che facete non mi
forme partore tempo poiché facete ciao
va bene tutto risoluto ora vai stanza
tomtom pa pronta wow non riuscivano più
a trattenersi fate tutte le porcate che
volete io devo andare in discarica
perfetto
sono i ragazzi il basso il grosso lo
smilzo e tutto pronto possiamo procedere
dove vuoi che lo portiamo via venerdì il
numero 13 ha idea di quanto sia lontano
da qui noi siamo diretti alla festa è il
massimo che possiamo fare è portartelo
li vedrò di accontentarmi sentito
muoviamoci
c'è via venerdì 13 raga la cosa più c'è
meraviglioso meraviglioso a posto può
andare in via venerdì 13 e non ho parole
ok è già qualcosa dai ma in tutto questo
io posso hanno finito di fare le cose
brutte non stanno e sono spariti quindi
io posso finalmente guardare cosa c'è
qua dentro
simpatico ma che schifo nahla non volevo
fartelo fare c'è scritto indossa ma non
volevo professore della ticosa
per questo volevo vedere perfetto per
spegnere perfetto grazie anelli presi
c'è un tizio passo avanti nascosto che
ci fai nascosto lì sotto
come dire potrei essermi cacciato in
guai seri e di preciso chiti starebbe
cercando questa stanza è un continuo via
vai di coppiette liscio mou che negli
ultimi tempi ho combinato qualche casino
di troppo hai tutta la mia stima ma cosa
hanno lenzuolo rosso puoi prenderlo
ok va bene usare il bagno nella vasca da
bagno sia il caso ti serve dell'altro
bagnoschiuma ne ho qui con me un flacone
basta per pappagallo coltiva dire sulla
pensilina della vasca posto fatto stai
facendo il bagno da 80 ore spiegami
perchè basca è school di certo non prima
che abbia finito col suo bagno
struccante tutto qua e tp ex la toilet
paper va bene in ogni caso prendi questo
per sdebitarmi del bagno schiuma è un po
bagnati cio non voglio nemmeno sapere
dove lo tenesse cos'è sta roba e il
museo è chiuso al pubblico
ma puoi entrare con questo passo qualora
si trovasse a passare da quelle parti
cioè fammi sapere se quella dell'otto lo
ha tutto sotto controllo
va bene quindi posso andare adesso ci ha
sbloccato il museo quindi vado al museo
posso questo il museo figata chiamata
robot scoperto lega b manca ancora
questo pezzo mi sa che la città ancora
da sbloccare
vai a nel frattempo c'è la cinematica
ancora la pasta
la sta facendo questo poi vedremo non
voglio sapere è la madonna è quindi per
oggi è tutto su the world il prossimo
episodio in teoria dovrebbe essere
l'ultimo in teoria non ne sono sicuro
però potrebbe essere l'ultimo quindi non
perdete vero però vi sia piaciuto
l'episodio come sento ragazzi
precisamente mi piace anche l'aiuto di
iniziare sono stati siete vi e noi ci
vediamo
[Musica]